as Democrats embrace fourth trimester
abortion they make the same mistake
Republicans have made on the abortion
debate in Reverse we will analyze the
undocumented infants then deep fakes
gene-editing and Cheerios finally the
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today the Democrats
destroy their entire abortion argument
we actually just have some breaking news
now it's being reported that Herman Cain
former presidential candidate nine nine
nine plan of 999 fame he is apparently
being considered by President Trump for
the Federal Reserve Board you know some
usually Thursday is kind of a slow news
day and we're just getting some of the
best news possible so we'll get into
that in a second but first let me tell
you about halo and specifically in an
indulgent product called indulgences
leave it to the only Catholic at this
outlet to be selling indulgences
Valentine's Day is fast approaching what
are you going to do it's the age-old
dilemma flowers are not original they
are way overpriced around Valentine's
Day and then take it from my experience
you they show up and they're wilted and
they'd last two days you could give them
chocolate but you know you know my sweet
little Alisa she likes to watch her
weight a little bit I mean she likes to
pay attention to things work out so any
two chocolates just throw out the rest
of the box don't do that do something
original and indulgent for Valentine's
Day something that rings the bell go to
indulgences dot store not calm dot store
together with halo healthy tribes
indulgences dad's store his partner to
create an indulgent line of hot beverage
mixes you just add water for some of the
most sumptuous mugs of hot cocoa and
other flavors that won't leave you
feeling guilty these are plant burning
with no animal ingredients mazaru matcha
yogi goji some others are fat burning
with fortify fortified with collagen
pink velvet whole lotta lovin I could go
on and on it's great hundred-percent
natural no added sugar loaded with MCT
oil 100% natural it's just a really
great product you don't need to feel
guilty about it
these indulgent beverages are available
in Valentine's Day gift packages as low
as thirty nine bucks but step up and be
a man get her the whole thing and save
even more by enrolling her in the
subscription program to get 12
additional flavors over the course of
the year act now and get ahead of the
valentine's crunch my listeners enter
cough fac ouvea vfe it check out save
ten percent if you order before February
third you'll save five dollars off
shipping and handling act quickly save
money get Valentine's Day coverage
you'll love it indulgences dot store
from a cocoa FFA CoV Effy Effy
10% savings save yourself to grief
indulgences dad's door don't screw it up
don't say dot-com that's store
indulgences with an S at the end that
store okay I love selling indulgences
this is really we're really in my
wheelhouse right now as the papist of
the daily wire this news about Herman
Cain I just want to get to it briefly
because it's terrific people are making
fun of Donald Trump for picking Herman
Cain because Herman Cain is supposed to
be some big idiot or something Herman
Cain is an extraordinarily intelligent
and successful man he was the CEO of a
major pizza company no not I'm not your
mom and pop shop down the street what
was it Godfather pizza he's actually
already served I believe on the Federal
Reserve Board in Kansas or somewhere one
of the Federal Reserve boards so he's
actually a pretty great candidate for
this and he's well known he's a public
figure he's been vetted by the media and
been vetted by voters I think it's a
terrific choice and he's a great
character I mean it's just a great
personage to have have out there so I'm
all for it it also takes the Federal
Reserve which is one of the most opaque
institutions in the history of
government and it makes it a little bit
more transparent by having a public
figure serving on the board if it's true
I think it's a great idea and bring it
on and it'll drive the left crazy
because Herman Cain drives them crazy so
you got my blessing a really dark story
that actually is rebounding well I think
for the pro-life movement is in Virginia
now governor Northam appears to be
one-upping andrew Cuomo in New York you
remember that last week Andrew Cuomo
cheered signed legislation that would
allow a baby to be killed one second
before it's born and now in Virginia
North amant stew out infanticide even
Andrew Cuomo by saying that you can kill
babies even after birth cheering it
along fourth trimester abortions here's
governor north him in his own words she
was pressed by a Republican delegate
about whether her bill would permit an
abortion even as a woman is essentially
dilating ready to give birth and she
answered that it would permit an
abortion at that stage of labor
do you support her measure and explain
in her answer yeah I'm you know I wasn't
there
Julie and I certainly can't speak for
delegate Tran but I will tell you one
first thing I would say this is why
decisions such as this should be made by
providers physicians and the mothers and
fathers that are involved there are you
know when we talk about third trimester
abortions these are done with the
consent of obviously the the mother with
the consent of the physicians more than
one physician by the way and it's done
in cases where there may be severe
deformities there may be a fetus that's
non-viable so listen to what he says
first of all he says I don't really want
to comment on this I'm really add this
is an awkward topic to talk about but
that's why decisions should be made by
the parents and the doctor so when he's
saying that this decision should be made
by the parents and the doctor he's
saying it's perfectly fine for parents
and/or doctors to kill babies one second
before they're born as the woman is
dilating but then I mean that's just the
sort of political empty slogan that
allows you to say nothing but sound like
you're saying something where it gets
really dark as he says look most third
trimester abortions they happen because
the baby's deformed oh you don't want
any of those deformed babies do you
don't want any of those imperfect babies
that those babies are garbage we should
just throw them out why would we want
any deformed people in our society
Oh yuck gross there was a video I wish
we had it we don't have the clip of a
man with Down syndrome testifying on
this point you'll remember last year
Iceland said that they had eliminated
Down syndrome in the country they didn't
eliminate Down syndrome they just kill
all the Down syndrome babies and he said
I am a man this man with Down syndrome
he says I am a man I'm a person stop you
don't need to eradicate me I want to be
treated as a person Liz look I am
manifestly a human being but according
to governor Northam that baby should be
killed because he's not perfect in
governor
or thumbs eyes morally speaking I'm sure
that that Down syndrome baby is far more
perfect than governor Northam who thinks
it's perfectly fine to kill babies after
they've been born but let's just listen
that's what you always hear well what if
it's deformed so what you're deformed
you're deform who isn't deformed who is
a perfect person show me a perfect
person I can point to one maybe to show
me are you a perfect person
no you're deformed maybe you're
physically deformed maybe you're
spiritually deformed or mentally
deformed you know look I I don't want to
talk myself down here I'm not exactly an
Adonis of a man I'm not an Olympian I
probably wouldn't do very well in armed
combat
I'm does that make me not perfect does
that make me yeah I guess I'm not
perfect does that mean that I should be
killed as I'm not even just before I'm
born but after I'm born
no but barbaric cultures do this and
thread all of history the vast majority
of barbaric cultures have done this have
killed babies and now we ostensibly a
civilized culture are delving into this
we're going back to our animal brutish
or beric roots to kill babies not just
before they're born but after they're
born he goes on this particular example
if a mother is in labor I can tell you
exactly what would happen the infant
would be delivered the infant would be
kept comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother so so I think
this was really blown out of proportion
blown out of proportion are you kidding
listen to you've made it worse governor
Northam governor Northam has made this
worse by saying the baby let's say that
the baby survives an abortion let's say
the let's say the baby is born that's
what he's saying the baby is born and
then if the mother and father don't want
the baby they won't help it to survive
but it gets even crazier than that
they're saying well okay the baby is
born it's alive and then if the mother
and father want to resuscitate it or
sustain it or keep it alive they can do
that and then they'll have a
conversation about whether they
to kill it whether they want to go right
back and kill it so you've got the baby
you try to kill it it's born you then
resuscitate it and then you decide if
you want to kill it again this is the
logical conclusion of abortion I love
that Democrats are finally honestly
speaking about the logical conclusion of
abortion and you're seeing it in all of
its gory logic in the natural conclusion
of abortion then the parents will talk
about if that's what's desired I think
there are a lot of parents who might
have various desires about their
fifteen-year-old teenage boys I think
there are a lot of parents who if you
ask them on any given day what their
desires are about keeping their teenage
boy or not keeping their teenage boy you
might get different answers that doesn't
mean that parents should be allowed to
do whatever they want with children
that's why we have child abuse laws
that's why we have child protection laws
the child is entitled to certain rights
as well not to be killed an hour after
it's born the baby's born it's sitting
there and then the mother says now
pish-posh I don't want it and okay and
then you're talking to your doctor and
okay the doctor says well you don't want
it it's only been out for an hour it's
only been moving around this earth for
an hour so we'll kill it because it's
being blown way out of proportion
according to governor Northam go he goes
on but again we want the government not
to be involved in these types of
decisions we want the decision to be
made by the the mothers and their
providers and and this is why Julie that
legislators most of whom are men by the
way shouldn't be telling a woman what
she should and shouldn't be doing with
her body this so what he said is
gobbledygook it doesn't mean anything he
said two sentences one was more
nonsensical than the last but to begin
he says we don't think the government
should be involved in this BS there you
never met one single action on earth
that you didn't think the government
should be involved in Democrats think
that the government should now be
involved in all of Industry that's what
the green new deal is you think the
government should be involved in 70% of
my paycheck and actually when you had
state and local in New York against up
to eighty two point three
percent of my paycheck you want the
government to be involved in my church
you want government to be involved in my
work you want the government to be
involved in my home you want the
government to be involved in what I eat
and fast-food in my car in my every
single thing you want the government to
be involved except protecting a baby
from being murdered and now which I want
to drop any sense of euphemisms at least
I can understand an honest debate where
you say is abortion identical to murder
or is it morally similar to murder I
understand that there is a ethical
debate to be had I think the answer is
relatively clear but I'm willing to use
more clinical language the baby is born
you have intent to kill it it is out
there it's kicking and crying moving its
little arms around there is no way that
you could jump through any sort of
mental gymnastics to pretend that that
isn't murder murder is the only instance
that governor Northam doesn't want the
government to be involved in your life
and then he says and this is why this is
why the legislature is most of whom are
men and we all know men are idiots yeah
well one is governor and I at least
agree at least one man in this situation
is a complete dummy well men most of you
know most of them were men that's why
they shouldn't be involved in these
decisions well first of all that
conclusion does not follow from that
premise
he's just describing murdering a baby
and then he says as an absolute non
sequitur
that's why legislators the majority of
whom are men should not be involved in
this decision why why is that show me
there's no logic at all that connects
those things but also men have brains
some men have brig men who are not
governor Northam or Andrew Cuomo have
brains and we can think about ethical
questions and political questions we
have for all of human history and
constructed every civilization ever in
all the history of the world so I think
that men can consider the question of
whether we should kill our children or
not in nature many fathers kill their
offspring this is bad
this is not a good that we shouldn't
emulate that in our societies men can
think about such a cop
it's it's for cowardly men I mean it's
for it and I don't mean to use the two
synonymously but it's for Democrats like
governor Northam who don't want to lead
they don't want to lead politically or
intellectually or ethically and so they
say well I'm a man I can't do anything
well I'm like I'm like Homer Simpson
yeah he is you can be men can be just
like that stereotype of the stupid idiot
father on sitcoms you know Ray Romano or
or Family Guy or whatever you and then
can be like that governor Northam
choosing to be like that he is he's
Homer Simpson governor Homer Simpson but
not all men are like that plenty of men
are men we need to talk about We the
People holsters oh I love We the People
holsters this is a new sponsor and we
love them they design everything
in-house We the People holsters offer
custom-made holsters all produced in the
USA they designed their own holsters
in-house means they don't use any
third-party molds for their holsters
instead they design every unique mold in
Las Vegas in order to best fit each and
every firearm perfectly they constantly
update their designs they add new
designs every month which lets them stay
up to date on the newest models that
come out We the People holsters even
have their own 3d design team who
measures every micro millimeter of their
guns to ensure the perfect fit these are
the best holsters I know a lot of you
like may our firearms enthusiasts their
unique and intuitive clip design allows
you to easily adjust both the can't and
ride of your holster so that it will fit
comfortably and securely at all times
you can replace the holster on your
waistband and change the angle it's just
terrific so customizable they have
custom designs in-house thin blue line
thin red line Constitution camo every
holster comes with a lifetime guarantee
every holster ships free if it's not a
perfect fit send it back for a refund
don't make the mistake of getting some
awful cheap holster and you think this
is plenty invest these artists is a
terrific product and they start as low
as 37 dollars right now my listeners can
go to We the People holsters comm slash
Knowles Canada wles enter promo code
Knowles Canada wles at checkout to get
10 bucks off your first holster that's
low as 37 dollars and shipping is free
with an additional 10 bucks off using my
promo code they are terrific products I
really love them we the people holsters
con slash Knowles kena wles promo code
Knowles Kendall you all es check out for
10 bucks off don't say I never did
nothing for you this is the only time
they want the government to be involved
the good side of this it's so you know
watching that clip you get so you just
want to go out and shake the guy but
there is a very good side to this which
is that right now the Democrats are
making exactly the same mistake on
pro-life that Republicans have made in
arguing pro-life for 20 years which is
they are taking the bait for them you
know the the Democrats have followed
their own logical conclusion logic to
its conclusion so now they're arguing
about pro-life at the moment of birth
what the Democrats used to always do was
try to argue about pro-life at the
moment of conception and so they would
say were you telling me a little egg
that has been fertilized for one hour
that's a baby and if you take that out
that's murder now this is a disingenuous
this argument because no abortion
happens at one day happens weeks and
weeks later and often in the second
trimester and now apparently in the
third trimester so it's a disingenuous
argument but in both instances you have
the left and the right following their
ideas to their logical conclusions so if
abortion is wrong if it's morally
similar to murder if it is murder then
it's not wrong at some arbitrary
deadline it's not wrong because it
sprouts a couple fingers or because it
opens its eyes or something like that
it's wrong from the beginning it's
intrinsically wrong it's wrong from the
moment of conception that's the logical
conclusion of abortion being wrong now
if abortion is not wrong if it's you
know it's just nothing that's perfectly
fine then it's it's not just that it's
not wrong at the moment of conception
it's it's not wrong at the moment of
birth and frankly if it's not wrong at
the moment of birth it's not wrong an
hour or two after birth and really
really if it's not wrong an hour - after
birth it's not wrong when they enter
kindergarten the
taking their idea to its logical
conclusion the left has been radicalized
it's been radicalized I think in part by
Donald Trump that has accelerated it but
this has been growing for a long time
the left radical abortion agenda on
demand at not just at the moment of
birth but after birth I love that we are
now arguing about abortion there because
as a matter of principle both sides have
to accept that the right has to accept
that life is life at the moment of
conception and the right has the left
rather has to accept that the fetus the
morally irrelevant embryo has to remain
morally irrelevant even at the moment of
birth they both have to follow that to
its conclusion but it just from a PR
perspective just from an optics
perspective for people who don't think
about this very deeply it's much easier
to argue for pro-life at the moment of
birth than it is at the fertilization of
an egg it just is we just see the
pictures this is why sonograms are so
helpful to the pro-life cause is that
you see that it's not just some little
blob of something it's a baby with a
face and eyes and nose and a mouth and
little fingers we it's not that the
fingers make it a morally significant
being it's that the fingers remind us
that it is a morally significant being
it's a person it's a human it's a it's a
living human being you know I I have
friends who support abortion i friends
who have had abortions who say that late
term abortion is infanticide now they
don't see that it's morally grave in the
second trimester in the first trimester
- they can't see that but they can all
see it at the end late when you look at
the public opinion polls over 80% 90% of
people oppose late term abortion duh
it's a it's so obviously a baby
let's keep Democrats fighting this here
this is this is absolutely a terrific
place to be having this battle governor
Northam I'm gonna donate to his campaign
so that he keeps going on the radio and
exposing his moral depravity the
mainstream media know this by the way
the mainstream media totally know this
they're the ones who always force us to
have the abortion debate two days after
conception they know this and so they're
not
last night MSNBC and CNN did not cover
governor Northam ska menswear he
advocated killing babies after they are
born they wouldn't cut is that a news
story no we have to talk about tweets
more don't we let's just taught no guys
look we don't have time to talk about a
sitting u.s. governor advocating the
slaughter of babies after they've been
born because we've got to talk about
Russia or something or whatever or Roger
stone or I don't know anything but that
anything but talking about abortion how
did the Democrats fall into this the
Democrats fell into this because we have
been pushing their buttons and President
Trump in particular has been pushing
their buttons Barack Obama pushed our
buttons he really got under our skin I
mean they that guy those little things
he would say you didn't build that you
didn't build your business somebody else
built that for you those little mmm he'd
said that the day that the Supreme Court
invents a fictional right to gay
marriage by redefining the essential
human institution the day that they does
that what does Obama do he paints the
White House rainbow colors in light he
just knew how to push our buttons and it
drove us a little crazy and now Trump is
doing the same thing he's pushing their
buttons and he's driving them a little
crazy you'd have to be crazy to advocate
killing a baby a day after it's born so
now what happens the Democrats are
telling us not to believe our lying eyes
they're telling us that a baby isn't a
baby it's only a baby if you say so it's
only a baby if it's desired it's radical
subjectivism we talked about it on the
show yesterday with the grievance study
guys this is born out of a culture which
increasingly undermines reality the the
sort of funny version of this I mean the
the not just darkly funny but just
bizarrely funny version of this is
something called deep fakes if you
haven't seen them deep fakes or videos
of real people that look totally real
and they're completely fake so the one
exit the ultimate deep fake came out
today this is a deep fake if you are
watching I'm sorry if you're listening I
think you were actually probably better
off
I can narrate it for you this is a deep
fake of Jennifer Lawrence receiving her
Golden Globe Award or speaking to the
press at the Golden Globes
with the head of
buscemi on her an image I never want to
see I want to spoon out my mind's eye
just having looked at it look at how
convincing this is it was just so you
see you can hear Jennifer Lawrence and
her her Steve Buscemi has is moving
around perfectly it's blinking oh the
mouth is moving just literally little
ticks the eyebrows going up even the
eyes are tracking oh this is so creepy
my least favorite I don't want to have
to say I need to call an exorcist I
don't want to have to say because who
knows when you're gonna run into these
people this needs to be burned to the
ground this needs to be set on fire and
burned until it is gone this is a very
terrifying thing it's called deep fakes
when this hits porn society is over when
deep fakes and actually I think it
already has there a Drudge Report it's
been covering mix-a-lot
I think Scarlett Johansson tried to sue
some people or was looking at legal
options because they were doing this
with Scarlett Johansson except in porn
and she basically concluded you can't
stop this there's no way to stop this
you can't stop the creation of fake
videos videos that really look like
you're doing something it could be you
you know a video of you committing an
axe murder and it would look really
convincing if Steve Buscemi can
convincingly become Jennifer Lawrence
anything is possible
and so when this I think once we get the
combination of sex robots virtual
reality and deep fakes that is the end
of society this is already affecting
Japan Japan is having it's already
dwindling population have now a
population crisis in part because of
porn and sex robots deep fakes mean that
you can turn any fantasy into reality
almost you can turn any fantasy into
virtual reality and this is going to
have some seriously negative effects not
just on weird videos on the internet
but on our culture in our politics what
this means what the the deep fakes mean
what the the combination we're seeing
sex robots and virtual reality porn what
what this means is that you can turn any
fantasy into a virtual reality and it's
symptomatic of a culture that we have
which is a culture of fantasy the
fantasy that the baby isn't a baby the
fantasy that men can be women and women
can be men the fantasy that indulging in
fantasy will make it a reality but it
won't it will make it a virtual reality
it's not real that this goes even
further it goes further than weird
videos or videos of Scarlett Johansson
that we certainly can't play on the show
this goes to the physical essence of the
human person there's a story at today a
San Francisco biochemist and
entrepreneur Josiah Zehner
is now making gene editing equipment
available to the public
where was that horrifying story story
that came out a couple days ago a couple
weeks ago about a baby in China who was
gene edited so some scientists went and
edited the genes of a baby and it came
out as a designer baby and this does not
just affect one baby this affects all of
that babies descendants this could
affect the human race forever and it's
being done in a laboratory with people
who should not be tooling around with
this stuff now this is being released to
consumers in the public the this guy
what's his name Josiah Zehner
he is making it such that you can inject
frogs with this and the frogs will
double in size in two months and
certainly people will start using this
on themselves
Zana already does use it on himself he's
done it at press conferences it'll just
go in and inject it with himself and
growth gene editing or whatever this is
the lie of self definition this is the
live self ownership it comes out of this
individualist culture that prioritizes
the radical subjective just you me me me
I'm me mine and tries to pretend the
fantasy is reality you don't own
yourself you don't have a right to
define reality you don't have any of
those rights this is the logical
conclusion of
liberalism lowercase L and capital L
liberalism that has been going on now
for centuries and it is terrifying
it is a bankrupt it is it is very wrong
fortunately we're starting to see the
illogic of it you know one of the great
advantages of conservatism and
conservative thought is that you can't
defeat reality fantasy can't defeat
reality you can try they've been trying
since the Garden of Eden but you can't
do it ultimately the real world will
assert itself before we go just really
quickly I have to comment on the
stupidest thing on Morning Joe yesterday
the then we'll get to the mailbag but to
call it the stupidest thing on Morning
Joe is really high praise I mean that
there's a lot of competition for that
segment on Morning Joe Mika Brzezinski
has likely presidential candidate Howard
Schultz on and she asks him the
important questions how much does an 18
ounce box of Cheerios cost in 18 ounce
box of materials like budgets for the VA
we don't ask you questions I don't eat
Cheerios I'm sorry okay it's very much
is it four bucks a lolly
yeah yeah right Howard Schultz does not
eat Cheerios because he is an adult I
also don't eat Cheerios because I am an
adult I have eggs for breakfast or if I
don't have time I'll have coffee I don't
I don't well I ate and the last time I
ate cereal I think I was nine years old
what what a stupid question what she's
doing it she's trying to play it off
like it's a harmless question what she's
saying is oh you're a billionaire you
don't you can't relate to people you
don't even know how much Cheerios go I
don't know how much Cheerios costs I eat
eggs for breakfast frankly I don't know
how much eggs cost because I'm married
when was the last time you Cobras insky
did her own grocery shopping are you
kidding me do we really think that maybe
she and Joe they make a date out of it
they have a fun time they go to Trader
Joe's or something give me a break how
stupid they're gonna try to do to
Schultz what they did to George Bush
George Bush the first which is he was
doing a press op at a grocery store and
he was asking perfectly reasonable
questions to the cashier lady and they
pretended that he didn't know what a
grocery scanner was because he's so out
of touch he doesn't buy Cheerios yeah
right he doesn't because he's an adult
give me a break
what a stupid he's a billionaire and he
is a billionaire he should not do his
own grocery shopping if Howard Schultz
were doing his own grocery shopping I
would seriously doubt his judgment you
know they they what when these
billionaires run as Democrats they have
a hard time because they have to play
into this stupid idea that you're
supposed to be ashamed of your success
Trump did not play into that Trump
probably exaggerated his wealth and it
was to his benefit that's how you got to
lean in if Schultz is gonna run as a as
a billionaire in this day and age with
his political party he is gonna have to
lean into it and he's gonna have to say
I don't know Mika how about you what a
stupid question Mika yeah I don't eat
Cheerios and I don't go grocery shopping
cuz I'm Howard Schultz I grew up in the
projects penniless and I became a
self-made billionaire and I got two
words for you Mika and they're not happy
birthday they're not caramel macchiato
okay we've got a lot of mailbag to get
to go over to daily wire calm ten bucks
a month hundred dollars for an annual
membership you get all the shows you
have to ask question you know what you
get you get this you get the leftist
here's tumblr because I don't know how
much a box of Cheerios costs but I know
how much a vessel of leftist tears costs
and the did you know what the price is
priceless that's the price be right back
in a couple seconds we'll be back with
the mailbag
I'm gonna get through all of these today
I'm probably not from coal hey Michael
what are the most important benefits of
the free market why do so many claim
that it is inherently for the rich and
against the common worker best coal well
the what aren't the benefits of the free
market the prosperity is a benefit
freedom Liberty is a benefit material
increase is a benefit I mean I suppose I
really should reverse that the Liberty
is the best part
economic freedom is the best part you're
free you are in a free country God wants
you to be free you have property you
have a right to your property you get to
you have a right to your labor you can
exchange that labor for goods and
services you can exchange that property
for goods and services
there's the freedom prosperity comes
along with it pope john paul ii in
chanting was honest talked about how
free markets are the most efficient way
to allocate resources and not they're
not just efficient but they come out of
your natural rights and your end of the
natural law they come out of your
property and that to which you are
entitled that's a good thing the reason
that the left is able to demagogue free
markets is envy because in free markets
to use Thatcher's example let's say
you've got the poor guy here and the
rich guy here the rich guy has got a
little bit more money than the poor guy
when you have free economies inequality
can be exacerbated but both groups are
getting richer just maybe the rich are
getting richer faster than the poor the
other thing that they forget is that
these economies are very dynamic so if
you're in the upper quintile of wealth
or income for one generation it's
unlikely that your family will get to
stay there because the the free markets
are so dynamic so more likely they'll
drop down a quintile maybe they'll drop
down two quintiles
and the lowest quintiles controlling for
cultural factors can increase in free
economies because they don't have to
game the system or deal with corrupt
politicians or deal with nepotism or
whatever it's much more dynamic and it's
much freer the way that the left
demagogues it is by playing on Envy say
that guy has more than me and I
want it it's just covetousness it's just
I mean there are there are Commandments
against this but that's all they play on
and unfortunately it works because we
have a broken human nature from Mark I
heard you guys had a hoop at the
workplace would you care to record a
game between you and Ben I no I would
not like to do that and if I were to
predict how that game would turn out I
think somehow we would both lose I don't
know how exactly but we would both I
think everybody would lose that game
from Jess dear Michael you seem like the
kind of charming fellow who can probably
handle the uber leftists of LA as well
as anyone how would you respond to
someone who asked your preferred
pronouns sir and sir
those are my preferred pronouns from
Rushton it's a great name hey Michael
over the past year I have been reading
incessantly trying to get myself more
enlightened I read Harvey Mansfield's
manliness because you mentioned it and I
found it really useful I'm wondering if
you have any other suggestions for other
important works of classic or modern
literature that I should read I'm not a
Catholic but I'm always trying to
understand more about them and have read
a little of st. Augustine and st. Teresa
of ávila Thanks well sure read all of
the read st. Agustin read all the Church
Fathers read the doctors of the church a
great idea for a book that you could
read right now in politics and
philosophy
you should read what I am now going
through again which is the conservative
mind by Russell Kirk just a terrific
book it's not read enough and in many
ways it's the beginning of the modern
conservative movement or the post-war
conservative movement from aruna dear
dr. Cerf effe you mentioned recently
that your degree is in history if God
forbid ben shapiro fired you and you
went to grad school for your PhD what
area of history would you study for your
dissertation are there any specific
subfields that are in dire need of a
conservative perspective or that are
simply of particular interest to you I
probably would study the medieval I love
the Middle Ages it's the most
misunderstood era in all of human
history it's a wonderful air it's a
brilliant era brilliant era of
scholarship the greatest poem ever
written was written during that era
the comedy by dante and wonderful air of
theology and philosophy that's great
you know the one downside of this is
it's probably the only field that is
conservative you know you don't become a
medieval list if you're not a little
weird and certainly a little
conservative I don't mean conservative
in the 1950s sense I mean conservative
in the 11 50s sense so I would probably
go into that I just couldn't resist it I
suppose if I wanted to be really helpful
to the culture I'd go into you know the
history of the Progressive Era or
something but come on man what can you
what are you asking of me you only have
one life I can't spend it doing that
from Keith Michael you're certainly the
biggest optimist at the Daily wire ever
since Trump conceded on the government
shutdown I've been feeling the
Conservatives keep losing even when they
are in power and I'm afraid
conservatives won't be in power for long
what reasons do I have to be optimistic
that conservative ideas will win out or
gain ground in the future I would like
to correct you I am NOT an optimist I
have hope I am hopeful but I am NOT an
optimist optimism and pessimism are two
sides of the same coin they're both
they're both disconnected from reality
the the pessimist says things can't get
any worse and the optimist says oh yes
they can
they there they're both silly they're
disconnected hope is real I have a real
hope grounded in a real fact obviously
first and foremost in Christ in my faith
that is where my hope comes from my
redeemer lives you can't keep me down it
was the last political revolution even
the threat of death doesn't scare me
that's a good reason to have hope but
I'm not optimistic I'm not I don't have
a sort of glib Sileo a little it's all
gonna be sunny no I don't think so at
all actually
I'm fairly confident that politics will
spiral and spiral but I have hope it
does I just have hope anyway despite the
politics spiraling because that's
reality the one bit of political hope
that I think I can give you is this well
I mentioned it probably 10 minutes ago
in the show reality has a way of
reasserting itself now you have a giant
little party the oldest continuous
running political party in the world the
Democrat Party is embracing the idea
that a baby is only a baby if a mother
wants it to be a baby it's embracing the
idea that men can really be women or
women can really be men it's embracing
total fantasy total self definition
ridiculous fantasies that we go there
was that video of a transgender guy who
clearly had mental issues who is six
foot two and he's walking into a store
he says I am clearly a woman I am and
then he's not clearly that that is I
don't mean to mock the guy he was acting
like a jerk but I don't mean to mock him
I mean to mock the acceptance of that
premise which is absurd that can't go on
forever his reality will reassert itself
when is that going to happen I'm not
quite so sure but you should not ground
your hope and politicians you'll only be
disappointed you have to ground real
hope in something more profound than
them
from James hello Michael love the show
my question is about the argument that
Jesus is just a retelling of the god
Mithra what are your opinions on this
sincerely James it's just nonsense this
is the thing that they always do the
lefties always do this Mithra for those
who don't know is a pagan god it's a
Roman pagan cult God for a while the
scholars tried to link it to a different
Persian God but that's sort of broken
down people don't really buy that
anymore so the reason that Jesus is not
a retelling of Mithra is that
Christianity predates the cult of Mithra
so Mithra might be a retelling of Christ
but it's not the other way around also
they don't really bear many similarities
they try to say that myth Row was
referred to as the Prince of Peace and
the this and the net and then that's
just isn't true
that's just totally made-up they do this
too with Christmas they say Christmas
there's no way it really happened on
December 25th the only reason that we
celebrated on December 25th is because
of the popularity of the pagan holiday
Sol Invictus or solely in victi also
that isn't true the celebration of
Christmas predates the popularity of Sol
Invictus Sol Invictus if anything was a
reaction to Christianity there are a
December 25th has been said
rated for Christmas since the earliest
days of Christianity in part this was
calculations from the resurrection from
the The Passion of Christ and they
calculated it within I think nine months
and that's how you arrive at December
25th but regardless the left as always
gets things exactly backwards so they
say
maybe it's a retelling of this pagan
tradition well maybe look at your
history books the pagan tradition came
after Christianity from Jonathan dear or
the smart one I was wondering if you
could elaborate on your return to Jesus
after being an atheist for a decade what
was the one event that began your
turnaround hashtag sign for Ben's stayed
for Michael how long do we have I mean
we've got like three minutes left I'll
tell you about my return to Christ I was
an atheist for 10 years more or less
agnostic probably would've called myself
an atheist from 13 to 23 ish it started
to break down and you can identify I
could identify a dozen moments that were
really key one thing that really started
to crack my atheism was that all of the
smartest people I met in college were
Christians and most of them were
Catholic or Eastern Orthodox some were
not you know there were a lot of smart
atheists and in particular I came across
the modal ontological argument for God
which I really found quite clever done
by Alvin Plantinga who's a Calvinist
philosopher out of Notre Dame then I
started looking at other arguments for
God some of the two mystic arguments for
God then I started looking at the
arguments against God and there aren't
really any then I delved into CS Lewis
was helpful in this then Chesterton
obviously and I became firmly convinced
that God exists and then the question is
what about Christ and if we think that
God exists then we must confront the
person of Christ the fact of Christ
because Christ is not just a poem or a
philosophy Christ is a man who claimed
that he was God and died was crucified
and then resurrected and then you have
to look at evidence for the resurrection
you have to look at evidence for Christ
and the evidence is overwhelming and
really only at that point did I begin to
have what would be recognizably
religious experience we
Chiz all which is everything and once
it's so much more convincing than
reading an argument a Thomas Aquinas
probably the greatest theologian ever to
live
said he had a religious vision and he
said all that I have written seems like
so much straw compared to what has been
revealed to me now but that came later
so that's a that's a brief overview we
if you and I ever grabbed a cigar I'm
sure we could go on about this for eight
or ten hours one more question from
Joseph hey Michael big fan of your work
my question is why do politicians tend
to speak in gibberish instead of
speaking plainly why cryptosystem in
lieu of speaking directly thanks Joe
it's because they're cowards so they
don't want to have to say anything or
take a position on any subject so they
try to speak out of both sides of their
mouth Barack Obama reportedly bragged
about this he said he could go into a
room and have every person in that room
even if they had different views think
that he was agreeing with them Bill
Clinton is the master of this he he was
asked I believe it was about the Gulf
War if he would go in and he said well
you know I would have my sympathies
would have been with the minority but I
would have reluctantly understood the
views of the majority what what was that
word salad
we'll get one more question it's because
the short answer is because they're
cowards from Adam Michael you said on
your podcast this week that you intend
to send your kids to a liberal arts
school you then went on to say that not
all kids need to go to college and that
some may instead be better served by
learning a trade but is it right for you
to presume presume that liberal arts is
the best education for your yet to be
born children thanks and love the show
Adam yes and no I think I can reasonably
expect that my children will be somewhat
like me and certainly for me that was
the best choice education also comes as
a result of other education so if I
hopefully am going to have a role in
educating my children not just when I
pay for college but earlier on I will
educate them toward a liberal education
now let's say they don't take to it
let's say that they just don't want to
do it I've got plenty of people in my
family who went straight into the
military
people who went straight to trade school
plenty of people who went straight to
work then you got it guide kids to where
they're leaning toward but I think I
think I'm sorry to say it's reasonable
to expect that my child will not be a
linebacker in the NFL probably not gonna
be a basketball player probably I don't
know I'm just judging and maybe I'm
prejudging so I would probably guide my
child in that direction but you know if
he proves his old man wrong then he can
do whatever he wants to do and I
certainly wouldn't want to force a kid
who would be better off in listing or
gonna trade school or starting to work i
wouldnt want to force him into a
quarter-million-dollar liberal education
that by that time probably will be worth
not very much okay that's our show I am
out of here but I will see you on Monday
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael no show see them
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19